c'est désormais confirmé par kiev licite
chance qu dernier verrou qui résistait à
l'armée russe dans la province de
louhansk est tombé n'y a que j'ai
commencé le commandement de notre armée
et actuels soldats de certains points du
front où l'ennemi a le plus grand
avantage du feu en particulier cela vaut
aussi pour l'isie de chance cela
signifie qu'une chose mais je nous
reviendrons grâce à notre tactique qui
grâce à l'augmentation de la fourniture
d'armes modernes pour ce week-end cette
chasse neige
depuis plus de 24 heures moscou
sous-entendait déjà sa victoire samedi
le président tchétchène ramzan kadirov
dans les troupes participantes au combat
aux côtés des russes et des séparatistes
du dombass
avait même diffuser ces images sur les
réseaux sociaux
des soldats paradant dans les rues de
licite chances que les sont déjà pensé
un retrait des troupes du crime de la
vie
moscou affirme aussi que la plupart des
villages aux alentours ont également été
conquis une avancée stratégique qui
permet à l'armée russe de se concentrer
désormais sur donetsk l'autre province
d'udon basse dont une partie reste aux
mains des ukrainiens et c'est justement
ce sont les villes de slovensko et crame
à tort sq qui se trouvent dans cette
zone que des frappes de missiles ont eu
lieu à la mi-journée
c'est le plus important bombardements de
ce l'audience de cette période récente
au moins une quinzaine d'incendiés de
nombreux morts et blessés
tenez bon nous sommes ensemble les
autorités ukrainiennes appelle de
nouveau les habitants de la région à
évacuer rapidement